the focus of the meeting is on the
defense ministers of the Netherlands
Germany and Norway together they've
agreed to take on the organization of a
new NATO Rapid Response Force made up of
around 5,000 troops Norway's defense
chief has talked up the importance of
expediting the process and I'm glad that
the Netherlands in Norway can join in as
we do right now I think this is one of
the most important deliverables from the
Wales summit and we are trying to do
this quickly the so-called spearhead
force is being set up amid rising
tensions over the Ukraine conflict nATO
Secretary General is blunt about
Russia's involvement has been a
substantial increase in the number of
heavy equipment are provided by Russia
in eastern Ukraine and we also have seen
training and we have seen Russian forces
in and we see errors and forces in
Ukraine debate in Washington over
whether to send weapons to the Ukrainian
government has caused waves amongst NATO
members outgoing US defense secretary
Chuck Hagel was at the talks to discuss
the matter NATO says it would be a wrong
decision laughing soo Lee fun in a
situation like this delivering weapons
is the wrong way to go we need a
sustainable solution for the region we
can see that the separatists have
potentially unlimited access to weapons
and heavy artillery's potencia also the
risk of things spiraling out of control
is too big estiga für eine escalations
bahala soo goes NATO wants to avoid an
arms race with Russia at all costs that
places high expectations on Francois
Hollande and Angela Merkel's talks in
Moscow